urlaub auf dem hausboot
ich bin unterwegs auf der müritz und
ihren weit verzweigten nebengewässern in
diesen corona sommer gibt es am größten
binnensee deutschlands einen echten run
auf die schwimmenden ferienhäuser hier
im hafen von rechlin warten viele boote
in allen größen auf die urlauber ganz
kleine für nur zwei personen oder
richtig große wie dieses haus boten
das haben sich ein paar freunde aus
magdeburg gescheitert sie treffen sich
schon seit jahren zum gemeinsamen boots
urlaub einmal angefragt ist es einfach
wie eine sucht man kommt einfach im weg
die natur grillen das wasser das
bootfahren selber hannover das ist schon
von jahr zu jahr schöner wetter passt
gut zur laub heißt aber auch reisen auf
engstem raum
man muss natürlich ein sa-mann lustig
super verstehen wenn man sich nicht
super versteht geht man verbot und
spricht nie wieder zusammen
die boote sind unterschiedlich
ausgestattet kojen bad und kombüse sind
bei den größeren mit drin
die preise liegen je nach saison und
komfort zwischen 650 und 135 euro pro
tag inklusive versicherung dagmar onkel
kunde und ihr team können sich für
urlauber anfragen kaum retten das liege
auch an corona virus glaubt sie ein
hausboot ist eine schwimmende
quarantäne-station man trifft niemand
anders man kann zu jedem seinen riesen
abstand halten und es nur mit seiner
familie zusammen
eigentlich etwas wunderbares und dazu
haben wir hier noch natur und
bademöglichkeiten nach lockerungen der
korona beschränkungen dürfen seit juni
auch die sechs magdeburger wieder
zusammen aufs boot bevor sie los können
gibt es eine einweisung die ist nur kurz
weil torsten henke den
sportbootführerschein hat unser echolot
wassertiefe und dem kiel
anschließend kann das ruder anzeige das
ruder platz steht ist es ja komplett das
gegenteil zum autor beim auto da denkt
man und denn dann lenkt das auto eben
und hier lenkt erstmal
nichts also ist alles zeitversetzt und
auch wie mit den bremsen wenn man
anhalten möchte mit dem auto dann steht
man und hier dauert es eben je nachdem
wie schnell man ist um wirklich zum
stehen zu kommen
wer keinen bootsführerschein hat den
erwartet eine dreistündige einweisung
der theorie werden ihnen die
verkehrszeichen erklärt in der praxis
wird er natürlich gezeigt wie das brot
funktioniert aber auch gemeinsam mit dem
ein weiterfahren gibt tatsächlich
anlegen ablegen wie stopp ich das boot
auf wie drehe ich solche dinge werden
denn geübt und zwar so lange bis es
klappt dann kann es endlich losgehen
raus aus dem hafen rauf auf die müritz
[Musik]
es ist einfach entspannung pur
diese fünf tage buttolo ist für mich wie
14 tage am strand liegen während die
magdeburger freunde weiter angeln lerne
ich ganz besondere bewohner der region
kennen
im bärenwald müritz leben braunbären
vornehmlich aus ost und südosteuropa
gerettet aus schlechter haltung und er
hat alter von drei jahren dort sein bein
verloren weil man dort noch einen
anderen werden mit rein gelassen hat in
diese bittere und haben die gekämpft und
dann gab es eine verletzung alle bären
hier teilen ein ähnliches schicksal
der neunjährige rocco musste aus seinem
viel zu kleinen käfig geschnitten werden
in denen er als bären junges gesteckt
und dann nie mehr raus gelassen wurde
im bärenwald hat er nun viel platz und
kann sich bei bedarf verstecken
sabine steinmeier und ihre kolleginnen
müssen ins bärengehege
sie verteilen und verstecken auf dem
gelände obst und gemüse während rocco
nebenan eingesperrt ist der bär wird
dann wieder rheinhessen mussten auf
futtersuche gewinner natur man damit
sind die dann natürlich auch schon
beschäftigt unser ansatz ja auch dass
wir die bären viel beschäftigen damit
sie nicht so lange weile haben also die
sich ein stück weit dass auch erarbeiten
ja der sack wird versteckt rocco soll
seiner nase folgen und ihn später finden
es ist ein training der instinkte manche
bären brauchen nach jahrelanger
sich haltung zeit bis sie wieder
natürliches verhalten zeigen zum
beispiel eine höhle graben für den
winterschlaf
man merkt dass hier auch im winter dass
die bären müde sind die wollen sich
nicht mehr bewegen und dann liegen die
dann vielleicht sogar betonplatte und
werden hier unter rausgeworfen aus ihren
boxen
obwohl sehe das nicht mehr wollen noch
schlimmer ergeht es manchen bären in der
ukraine erzählte sabine steinmeier
dort werden heute noch hunde an
wehrlosen bären für die jagd scharf
gemacht der bär hat keine chance der ist
eine kette und hat nur die kette hat nur
in begrenzten radius und dann werden die
hunde auf ihn drauf gelassen und der
wird nur gejagt und gehetzt den laufen
schon die schaum aus dem mund der kann
auch nicht mehr
aber die lassen die hunde dann einfach
weiter laufen
rocco aus albanien darf jetzt auf
futtersuche gehen den sack mit den
leckereien findet er schnell dank seines
guten geruchssinn
es ist ein neues leben für ihn im
bärenwald müritz
zurück aufs boot der magdeburger
urlauber die haben inzwischen begonnen
sich für die nächsten tage einzurichten
unter deck ist platz für maximal neun
personen drei kajüten zwei bäder und ein
komplize die freunde haben reichlich
proviant mitgebracht wir haben also
wirklich überhaupt nicht das problem
euro anhalten zu müssen wir haben
wirklich keine lebensmittel box und das
ist eigentlich auch sozial wirklich ein
paar einmal komplett nichts mit dem zu
tun haben so ungefähr zu sein
platzmangel macht erfinderisch
früher haben wir mal 60 euro für eine
woche mit an bord genommen aber
mittlerweile haben wir dieses volkes
entdeckt was natürlich mittlerweile nur
3 1 liter tetrapacks ergibt was
natürlich ganz viel platzersparnis in
der kombüse wechseln sich die männer ab
jeder ist mal dran mit kochen gebracht
das von zu hause oder aber heute uns
dazu entschlossen schönen leckeren
italienischen staat ist also das loch an
gemacht doch bis zum abendessen dauert
noch jetzt gibt es erstmal kaffee
inzwischen steuert und torsten henke
durch den mirror kanal der autohändler
aus magdeburg hat schon oft große
hausboote mit freunden gemietet und
genießt die fahrt jedes mal wenn man
kann komplett in den hebel umlegen man
denkt an nichts anderes mehr mann ist in
der freien natur
man lässt alle sorgen und probleme in
dem moment zu hause freut sich nur noch
freut sich natürlich auch auf die jungs
hier
man freut sich auf den schönen urlaub im
kanal dafür nicht schneller als 9
stundenkilometer fahren und beim alkohol
muss er sich jetzt zurückhalten
bei mehr als 0,5 promille im blut drohen
drastische strafen nach so vielen
urlauben hatte das boot inzwischen gut
im griff das ist längst nicht bei allen
freizeit geben so ein bote von formel
kommen und die dann auch nicht ganz ohne
schrift kannte lang fahren dann wird das
schon mal enger und da muss man einfach
so bewahren und sagen okay ich war so
weit rechts rüber wie es geht
man hat eben viele leute die es zum
ersten mal machen die ein entgegenkommen
die dann auch so zick zack fahren
das ist manchmal schon sehr interessant
ja auf den seen darf überall geankert
werden nur nicht in gekennzeichneten
fahrerinnen oder wo es aus naturschutz
gründen verboten ist
stau gibt es zuweilen auch auf
wasserstraßen vor allem verschlossen
braucht es in der hauptsaison geduld
leider ist es so da durch das ist immer
mehr boote werden die natürlich auf den
gewässern fahren wartet man manchmal
auch denn dadurch 3 45 stunden die
freundin nehmen es gelassen
wasser und wald so weit der blick reicht
dem müritz-nationalpark lässt sich gut
hier dem kanu auf der havel erkunden
anemone henning bietet individuelle
touren durch die kernzonen des
nationalparks an
motorboote sind hier nicht erlaubt es
herrscht nahezu stille
ich habe viele urlauber geraden
natürlich aus dem berliner bereich wenn
wir da mal so ganz still sind und
horchen was auch kaum noch ein mensch
aus hält nach zehn sekunden wollen alles
schon wieder erzählen und dich dann
immer frage was sie gerade so gehört
haben und dann sagen sie sind gruseln
sich oder tag hier mal warum und dann
sagen sie ja wir keine zivilisations
geräusche gut daran lernt man schon wie
ride becken meister von der natur sind
in den kernzonen des nationalparks ist
die natur sich selbst überlassen
umgefallene bäume bleiben liegen und
dienen so noch vögeln und insekten nur
für die partner werden die wege frei
gehalten deutscher wald ist ja in der
regel aufgeräumt kein totholz und das
wird hier prinzip alles wieder
rückgängig
karl-heinz marek aus blankenburg im harz
kommt schon seit zehn jahren hierher
einfach echt zum erholen
das natürlich nur was für naturliebhaber
irgendwelche bemühungen die karussell
oder sowas sucht der ist erklärt dann
platzt hier lässt sich noch natur pur
erleben im müritz nationalpark
an der mirror schleuse geht es endlich
weiter
für torsten henke und seine freundin
dann natürlich der größte fehler wenn
man die leinen richtig fest macht als ob
man anlegen will wenn denn die schleuse
oder das wasser nach unten geht dass man
dann auf einer seite dranhängt kriegt
das boot nicht mehr los muss mit einem
messer die leinen durchschneiden
in der schleuse ist teamarbeit gefragt
wenn also das erste mal bot fährst dann
ist das schon ein bisschen aufregend ja
weil ja immer gucken muss
wie ist das büro stets hast du zu engen
hast du zu dicht bist du zu weit
aber inzwischen ist das eine gelungene
abwechslung her weil da einfach mal ein
bisschen was zu tun hast pro kanal zu
schippern drei meter geht es nach unten
in nur wenigen minuten dann können wir
weiter andere boote immer im blick
wenn ihr zum beispiel kanufahrer oder so
was kommen sollte mal ein bisschen gas
wegnehmen damit die dann nicht so viel
weltkriegen so ein bisschen gegenseitige
rücksichtnahme ist ja auch was auch sehr
viel wert
im mirror see an der schlossinsel wollen
die sechs freunde schließlich für die
nacht anlegen
hier gibt es einen sitz der herzige von
mecklenburg strelitz aus dem achtzehnten
jahrhundert und einen fischer der frisch
geräuchertes aus seinem ofen holt
im hafen wartet eine helfende hand
die liegegebühren für die nacht
berechnen sich nach der bootslänge meist
ein zwei euro pro meter zu entrichten
beim hafenmeister wer im sommer 2020
noch ein hausboot für die ferien mieten
will muss etwas glück haben und flexibel
sein bei ort und reisezeit